apparently Ben Shapiro believes that
localities could or should ban men and
we will ban men from wearing women's
clothes you heard that right according
to the pro-freedom folks it's not enough
that we live in a society where people
can wear whatever they want we need to
restrict what people can wear on the
basis of their gender now I'm gonna play
the clip for you and you're gonna notice
that there are some real complexities
here about how you would even enforce
this I would argue it's not even legal
but remember this is someone who's about
freedom and listen to what he's calling
for
she's wearing dresses and skirts be
illegal for men in public if so should
wearing pants for women be illegal in
public well pants not so much because
there is a female version of pants that
is nearly indistinguishable in many
cases from from male bands but men
wearing traditional female clothing in
public I think there's a case the local
Zone that local community should be able
to stop at sure I mean they have local
laws about being naked or oranges and
exposure or at least we used to
what
because he's reading some chat message
now
see if he says more about it
looking very closely at chat messages I
guess
have I seen Kyle dunnigan's fresh
present DC work okay no he's off he's
off to something else now so the
argument here is municipalities should
be allowed to ban men from wearing
women's clothing I guess under some kind
of indecency thing if you can ban nudity
then you could ban a man from wearing a
skirt this is
absurdly stupid absurdly stupid and
again it's counter to the principle of
low regulation and freedom and liberty
that these right-wingers claim to
espouse number one
almost certainly this would be against
the law an ordinance at the local level
to restrict what clothing people can
wear based on the traditional gender
placement of that clothing would
probably be against the law the
Constitution guarantees the right to
freedom of expression that includes the
right to dress however you want if you
attempt to restrict that based on gender
Norms you would almost certainly violate
the equal protection Clause of the 14th
Amendment they say they're for Law and
Order this would almost certainly be
illegal they will often cite the
obscenity exemption arguing that a man
in a skirt is somehow obscene is going
to be a very very tough legal argument
to make but let's put legality aside for
a second talk about the Practical
absurdity of this proposal for starters
what are traditional women's clothes the
answer varies by society and it varies
by time period In some cultures men wear
skirts or dresses in others women wear
pants or other items that might be
considered mask the idea that there is a
clear and fixed line between what when
men and women should wear is untrue in
addition to that traditional wear even
within the United States there are
dramatic cultural differences between
what is typical between what is seen
regularly in different parts of the
country but beyond that
Scotland has men that wear kilts I guess
in Los Angeles men quote don't wear
kilts but is it based on where you're
from or where you are and then can you
actually say to Scotsman in La who want
to wear a kilt you can't do that because
here the men don't wear it and in
Scotland it's just ridiculous it is
ridiculous and it is another one of
these ideas from the so-called Freedom
crowd to control people's lives based on
arbitrary
changing and outdated Notions of gender
roles and there's this broader pattern
of them wanting to do this it's on
access to health care we're going to
decide what procedures are legal and
when it's on voting no early voting and
no mail in voting and no voting in the
poor Democratic areas or whatever the
right to exist without fear of
discrimination oh let's ban men from
wearing women's clothes every single
instance of this needs to be pushed back
against if they claim to be about
individual freedom
then they can't also argue for something
that would arguably violate the
constitution on the basis of the
opinions of what manly men are supposed
to wear it's absurd it's ridiculous and
it goes against what they want you to
believe they actually stand for make
sure you're subscribed on YouTube
youtube.com slash that's a forward slash
the David Pacman show we'll take a very
quick break what a program today really
folks one of the best ways to support
this show is by supporting our sponsors
today one of those sponsors is sheath
underwear it is spring temperatures are
rising many of us know all too well
about the sweating and the sticking and
the chafing but that's only when you use
traditional underwear when you use
sheath underwear it's no longer a
problem sheath underwear is
ergonomically designed lined with
separate compartments in the front to
keep everything dry cool and separate
and to keep you comfortable they come in
a zillion different designs something
for everybody the quality is amazing
super long lasting put an end to the
readjusting and the sweating and the
shifting uncomfortably sheath underwear
is really a lifesaver you will thank
yourself it's a unique product you've
got to try at least once to see for
yourself and my audience gets 20 off
with code Pacman go to
sheathunderwear.com slash Pacman the
link is down below